quanta gente 2014 bem ao final desse ano
nós vamos ter eleições eleições para
governador eleições para presidente da
república e inúmeros cargos legislativos
e como é típico das eleições nesses
tempos que a gente vai tendo a boa parte
das conversas sobre política vão
acontecer online então quero fazer uma
provocação para vocês três pontos três
pontos pra gente lembrar antes de entrar
em qualquer conversa sobre política na
internet tenho certeza de que vão ser
boas contribuições para a nossa
democracia
o primeiro ponto é uma história uma
história que a gente conta em que
gráficos essa curva e essa curva isso
são os últimos oito anos da história da
economia mundial o pib
cada ponto representa um ano a partir de
2005 última 2013
e se a reta vai pra cima porque o pib
está crescendo se vai para baixo
o bebê está descendo pois bem quem é que
puxa esse pib quem puxa esse pique
impulso e faz o desenho dessa curva na
verdade é a maior economia do mundo são
os estados unidos da américa
e ninguém precisa acompanhar o
noticiário econômico para saber que em
2008 e na sequência 2009 nós tivemos a
pior crise de bolsa de valores desde
1929 quando teve início a grande
depressão só estados unidos não é
condizente com a nossa história começa a
nossa história começa em outro país
num país do norte da áfrica com países
árabes chamado tunísia a tunísia havia
bem aí de repente 2008 uma queda em 2009
uma segunda queda em direção a 2010
diferentemente do que aconteceu nos
estados unidos a tunísia não conseguiu
recuperar três anos com isso
economicamente o que aconteceu
a população foi às ruas da barra não deu
para aguentar um ano nas ruas dois anos
nas ruas
o resultado a ditadura que já durava há
décadas caiu um governo foi
democraticamente eleito eles conseguiram
se recuperar economicamente a população
voltou para as ruas um país vizinho
a gente fala evidentemente da primavera
árabe eu tenho certeza que vocês já
ouviram falar de toda essa história
levando suas feitas pelo facebook
mudanças radicais acontecendo em todo
mundo aliás nos últimos anos inúmeros
países foram para as ruas
no caso do egito eles até foram bem 2008
2009 foi difícil 2010 continua difícil
exatamente como na polícia na tunísia
2011 2012 e 2013 população nas ruas
qual foi a diferença entre egito e
tunísia a diferença entre egito e
tunísia é que o governo democraticamente
eleito de mohamed nor se o primeiro
governo democraticamente eleito da
história do egito não conseguiu fazer a
recuperação econômica que o país
precisava a população continua nas ruas
houve um golpe de estado no um novo
golpe militar que aliás é o hábito
egípcio no ocidente o século 20
enfim a gente não sabe como é essa
história termina índia índia é um país
muito diferente no brasil nem tanto
economicamente muito parecido com o que
acontece com a índia em 2008 uma ligeira
queda em 2009 a coisa vai difícil mas e
2010 que é o ano em qual as tunisia e da
grécia também europa no ano que essa
turma vai pra ruas assim como nos
estados unidos a índia consegue algum
tipo de crescimento econômico só de 2011
e novamente uma queda nesse período já
tem bastante gente nas ruas em vários
pontos da zona do mundo
os indianos não sabem ainda o que vai
acontecer em 2012 e 2013
a paciência da população esgota
população nas ruas
só que aí vocês vão se virar para mim
falar vocês que acompanhe o noticiário é
uma linda história diferente
na índia as pessoas foram para as ruas
quatro estupros estupros coletivos
acontecendo a toda hora não tão certinho
basta
o problema é que estes estupros
acontecem há várias décadas na história
da índia e no entanto dessa vez a
população esgotou o que faz o que faz
essa última gota d'água fazer um balde
transbordar em que momento que as
pequenas grandes violências do cotidiano
fazem com que as pessoas percam a
paciência e tomem as ruas england
com milhões de pessoas invariavelmente é
a economia é quando a vida começa a
ficar difícil é quando de repente o
dinheiro para comprar comida não tá
dando o aluguel está mais difícil
história
histórico em 2008 o nosso presidente
luiz inácio lula da silva se virou para
todos nós falou olha a economia
brasileira o crescimento da economia
brasileira não é vôo de galinha e de
fato é verdade a gente teve uma ligeira
queda em 2008 a queda um pouco mais
forte em 2009 mas em 2010 nós nos
recuperamos
assim como houve recuperação americana a
gente acompanhou pô tá tudo bem vamos
comparar com a índia foi o que aconteceu
com a indy aqui
no mesmo momento o brasil e olha que é
impressionante como são dois países dos
brics são dois países incrivelmente
independente de como andam as economias
tanto de ensino enquanto os estados
unidos
e olha como o desenho do sobe e desce
das economias da índia e do brasil são
parecidos então a gente tinha enquanto a
tunísia foi para as ruas porque tinha
time enfrentando as dificuldades não
entende o brasil estava se recuperando
estava tudo bem presente grécia índia
tunísia egito e todo mundo indo para as
ruas
a gente tava bem só que no segundo ano
de queda
os indianos no final de 2012 foram para
as ruas os brasileiros
a gente é mais paciente a gente não foi
para as ruas em 2013 bem a história é um
pouco diferente
vinte centavos corrupção dificuldades o
que acontece o que faz com que vários
problemas que com os quais nós
convivemos o tempo todo o que faz com
que aquelas pequenas violências com as
quais nós nos habituamos de repente
explosão façam com que a gente vá para
as ruas o que é que provoca isso de
repente você não consegue mais pagar o
aluguel daquele bairro no qual você foi
criado isso aconteceu com muitas
famílias de classe média no rio e em são
paulo
de repente a comida está ficando muito
mais caros serviços não melhorou de
qualidade no entanto
estão encarecendo a vida está complicada
temos pleno emprego a situação é grave
mas não tanto a economia história e
escalável que foi assessor do presidente
americano bill clinton costumava dizer
olha o que faz com que o humor das
populações bom na direção favorável
direção desfavorável os governos
invariavelmente é a economia
se a economia está bem as coisas também
se a economia está mal as coisas não vão
tão bem
segundo ponto com lembrar uma essência
que mais se desenvolveu ao longo do
século 20 foi a psicologia e uma das
coisas que a gente aprender psicologia é
que existem cinco traços que determinam
a nossa personalidade a gente tem um
pouco mais um pouco menos de outro e é
mais ou menos um equilíbrio aí que
acontece em cada um de nós
individualmente a respeito desses cinco
traços que determina que tipo de pessoas
somos nós que qual é personalidade que
nós temos pois bem
um grupo de cientistas políticos dos
anos 60 para cá começou a perceber que
existe um padrão ocorrendo entre como
nós nos posicionamos politicamente e
dois desses cinco traços
um deles é o de abertura experiências
uma pessoa aberta experiência uma pessoa
curiosa uma pessoa imaginativa uma
pessoa que tem interesse por arte uma
pessoa mais fechada a experiência de uma
pessoa mais tradicional uma pessoa que
se sente desconfortável quando as coisas
mudam uma pessoa por outro lado muito
objetiva muito confiante de certa forma
não vamos por aqui por aqui por aqui
outro traço esta versão uma pessoa muito
extrovertida uma pessoa que demonstra
uma energia muito grande ela é como se
uma pessoa que se alimentasse de gente
ao redor uma pessoa que nos seus colegas
de trabalho e suas famílias os amigos
aquilo parece que alimenta a energisa
uma pessoa introvertida e não vamos
competir confundir aqui quando a gente
fala de psicologia
não vamos confundir introversão
consumidores são coisas diferentes
são pessoas mais discretas na por outro
lado são pessoas que estão muito
confortáveis sozinhas elas não precisa
o de outras pessoas ao redor pra a se
mexer para ganhar energia lá estão têm
sozinhos e não necessariamente estão
mais juntos
bem esses dois traços a gente começou a
perceber inúmeros cientistas de várias
pesquisas começaram a demonstrar pessoas
que tendem a ser mais aberta às
experiências e suas mais extrovertidos
tendem a ser pessoas de esquerda pessoas
por outro lado mais introvertidos mais
fechadas há experiências são pessoas de
direita
outro ponto interessante isso essas duas
características determinam muito mais
qual se ouve a 0 e ideológico do que um
lugar em que você tá socialmente
você pode ser uma pessoa riquíssima que
talvez tivesse todo interesse em uma
política de direita no entanto se você
está vertido se você é aberta a
experiência que você é uma pessoa de
esquerda é uma coisa uma pessoa pobre
que no entanto seja introvertida talvez
pudesse se beneficiar por grandes planos
de governo mais alinhados que os cães
nem tanto aquela pessoa vai ser de
direita
talvez eu acho que isso é o mais
incrível de tudo isso vem dos nossos
gênios
em grande parte isso tem muito mais a
ver com a quem nós somos geneticamente
do que tenha a ver com a maneira como
nós fomos criados às vezes dois irmãos
dos mesmos pais um é de direita e outro
de esquerda
no fim das contas só quer uma coisa
gente se você direita ou de esquerda
isso não vem porque vai ser mais ou
menos inteligente e isso não vem porque
você teve uma vida assim uma vida à sdu
isso não tem [ __ ] não tem nada a ver
com se você tem um bom caráter
o mau caráter a gente nasce assim 0
ponto
sabe como é que a gente costumava
começar sua política a gente costumava
conversar sobre política em família no
jantar de domingo no almoço de domingo
a gente começava sobre política no
trabalho no cafezinho no chope com os
amigos em uma crise enorme diferença
quando a gente está conversando
pessoalmente a gente está vendo que o
sujeito está ficando irritada a gente já
button e quem quer provocar uma briga
afinal de contas a gente vai dando uma
moderada só que de repente começou a
conversar sobre política nas caixas de
comentários na internet
em um dos primeiros problemas nas caixas
de comentários internet é o seguinte a
gente não tinha mais vaga idéia de que
cada pessoa está fazendo outro lado
caixas de comentários na internet são
exatamente como aldeia deve ser isso ou
seja qualquer pequena fagulha faz com
que tudo história numa pancadaria e
evidentemente alguém em algum momento
vai ser comparado com a sofrida a
quantidade de genocida que existe na
internet é impressionante
o segundo ponto é que a internet é uma
máquina que muda a maneira como a gente
não se forma por que o google por
exemplo escolhe depois de a gente fazer
inúmeras pesquisas clicar em número os
resultados o google escolhe o que vai
nos mostrar partindo do princípio que
nós queremos ver determinadas coisas e
não outras
no facebook até pior porque o facebook
escolhe que amigos e conhecidos eles vão
apresentar na sua linha do tempo na sua
timeline
são aquelas pessoas cujos pulsos você
comenta mais enquanto expulso você clica
no botão curtir com mais freqüência as
pessoas que você demais são pessoas que
pensam de forma mais parecida com você
a gente vê cada vez menos apresentada
pontos de vista divergentes e perde tudo
que parte disso está em nós sabia porque
nós cada vez mais procuramos sites nos
quais a gente sabe que vão aparecer
coisas com as quais nós concordemos no
tempo dos livros não era assim no tempo
que a gente se informava basicamente por
jornais e revistas era muito diferente
porque embora o nível o número de
publicações número de fontes de
informação fosse muito menor
as vinte fatalmente será apresentada
pontos de vista muito diverso heróica
mesmo a gente tem a mais incrível
tecnologia de informação jamais criada a
gente está exposto uma quantidade de
informação como jamais existiu na
história da humanidade e cada vez a
gente procura de mais coisas com as
quais a gente já sabe previamente que a
gente vai concordar em ser lembrado já
escreveu aquele assessor de bill clinton
essa mulher dele meu método
ela também uma das mais bem pagas
assessora uma das mais bem pagas de
estrategistas políticos eleitorais dos
estados unidos mas tem uma pequena
diferença a trabalhava presidente george
w.bush meta é de direita pegou o carro
viu é de esquerda
casados há décadas são os casais mais
conhecidos de washington capital dos
estados unidos está presente para vocês
um desafio que não é apenas sair pela
internet procurando pontos de vista
distintos de vocês mas o que isso é
ao encontrar pontos de vista de cintos
se não encontrar amor lá pelo menos
enquanto a inteligência se a gente for
capaz de conseguir de coisas com as
quais discorda no entanto respeitando
quem está manifestando aquelas opiniões
percebendo que há uma inteligência para
ali não só a gente vai começar a ter
conversas mais inteligentes como a gente
certamente vai começar a ter conversas
muito mais produtivas e é exatamente
isso que alimenta uma democracia
obrigado
ah